[Musique]
bonjour serge letchimy bonjour bonjour à
toute la martinique lors de président du
parti progressiste martiniquais candidat
à votre succession à fort-de-france pour
les législatives avant tout une réaction
à l'édito de jean marc partir bilan
mitigé pour la présidence de françois
hollande
ouais je partage l'analyse de jean marc
très synthétique mais qui résume bien un
peu ce qui s'est passé en martinique
avec la gauche et qui a créé deux
déceptions déception cependant on peut
pas dire que tout le bilan est négatif
il ya quand même beaucoup d'apports
notamment la loi sur l'égalité réelle
qui a permis juste avant la fin de la
mandature de relever les des petites
retraites de travailler sur le
complément familial pour m ont
pratiquement au même niveau d'ici trois
ans qu'au niveau national la question de
la transition énergétique a été bien
aborder la question de la coopération
régionale
la question des enjeux liés aux
habilitations qui ont été accordés pour
permettre à la menthe y en avoir plus de
pouvoir sous plan local il ya quelques
avancées mais globalement jean-marc
parfaitement raison le président
emmanuel macron doit nommer son premier
ministre aujourd'hui il pourrait s'agir
d' edouard philippe député-maire les
républicains du havre il fait office
donc deux favoris comment analysez-vous
cette possibilité d'avoir un premier
ministre issu des républicains bon je
veux d'abord salué la victoire du
maniema qu'on sait c'est très courageux
ce qu'il a fait en très peu de temps le
nord il a réussi à m
des conditions nécessaires à une
victoire dans un contexte extrêmement
difficile
cependant on voit bien que sont ni
droite ni gauche
comment ça il faut faire des choix on
peut pas rester dans le milieu tout le
temps entre deux chaises quoi donc si
c'est edouard philippe seront sait rien
du tout on va avancer sereinement
jusqu'à maintenant c'est donc les
républicains donc c'est la droite qui
sera choisi à tête du pays bon je
respecte parce que c'était sale à
l'orientation prise par le président il
reste fidèle à lui même et le fait de
nommer
après un premier mise de droite c'est
une orientation extrêmement précis
s'agit de rallyes maximum de personnes
de la droite
quel sera le résultat à l'assemblée
nationale parce que il faut une majorité
de gestion parce que vous pouvez être
président et vous n'avez pas de majorité
de gestion ça veut dire vous êtes en
situation de cohabitation
là il qu'apple ouvre un nouveau prix je
pense en mettant quelqu'un de doigts que
pour essayer de rassembler le maximum de
personnes à droite cela veut dire que la
partie gauche qu'il défend des risque
d'en pâtir nôtre nous verrons est-ce que
c'est surprenant
non c'est pas ça me surprend pas parce
que si si on n'avait pas cette position
dès le départ il a été extrêmement clair
il n'a pas joué avec les gens ils ne
doivent ni gauche avait dire et c'est
même beaucoup démarquer de françois
hollande même si françois hollande
essayer de le rattraper à la fin et est
par rapport à sa victoire mais il a été
extrêmement clair maintenant je ne
participe pas à ce genre d' analyse là
ni droite ni gauche je pense vraiment qu
à une famille s'il s'agit pas d'avoir
une l'idéologie intégriste quoi mais
elle famille politique on est de gauche
on peut avoir une tendance libérale au
social démocratie ça c'est des variantes
mais on a quand même famille de pensée
il ya trop de personnes qui ont été
tuées qui se sont battus il ya trop de
victoire ou de défaite notamment toutes
les avancées sociales et grande liberté
c'est la gauche donc je n'ai pas voulu
lâcher la gauche même si j'étais
conscient du bilan assez négatif de la
gauche va y revenir à quoi serez-vous
attentifs pendant ce quinquennat notice
annonce les intérêts supérieurs du
peuple martiniquais
c'est ce qui m'intéresse et puis
deuxièmement les grandes questions liées
mais à la dignité humaine d'ailleurs
c'est ce que j'ai apprécié chez makro
nous avons décidé de vous théo 2e théo
produit c'est qu'elles se dégradent base
républicaine de la dignité humaine c'est
certainement le candidat qui est allé le
plus loin possible
quand il a parlé de crime contre
l'humanité et pour la colonisation j'ai
apprécié beaucoup à ce que certains
leurs critiques et 1,10 à oui mais c'est
l' esclavage qui est que me contre
l'humanité ah bon parce que l'esclavagé
n'y a pas une espèce de cadres qui
s'appelle la colonisation les déserts
que ce qui fait qu'à clair là dessus
donc sur ce plan là le fait de rester
dans l'europe il rassure mais je sais
très attentif au développement du pays
on a quand même trois quatre grands
problèmes beaucoup mais le chômage des
jeunes
le vieillissement de la population et
notre capacité à avoir le maximum de
toute suffisance la vie chère quand on a
une vie chère en plus on a quelques
buttes ou fusco où son coup de blues
existants avec des augmentations de
l'essence du gazole et de la fiscalité
locale dans le temps le sud et bientôt
éventuellement un doublement d'octobre
et régionales eh bien il faut faire très
attention à ne pas punir la population
encore à nouveau j'ai envie de vous dire
serge letchimy tout ça pour ça tout ça
pour ont au final appelés à voter au
deuxième tour
emmanuel macron est ce que le ppm ne
sais pas trop impliquée
d'abord de la première de la gauche en
appelant abouti valls puis ensuite
soutenant benoît hamon et faisons mieux
allant même plus loin que le ps huy même
en excluant trois de ses membres
parce qu'ils avaient alpes les agoutis
macron et pour au final se range à leur
choix non attention voilà je m'excuse
mais je peux vous dire que vous êtes
trompés mais et paient jamais
d'exclusion par des vomissements think
ya une suspension suspension appareils
oui mais bon personne a été suspendu
parce que le ps à sa manière fonctionner
son niveau de fonctionnement et il n'ya
jamais d'exclusion d'ailleurs il n'ya
jamais de problèmes macro bébert
d'ailleurs nous avons parrainé mâcon
personne ne le dit donc il y avait des
problèmes avec les trois non non pas du
tout il y a
vous avez une essence à plat comité
national il y avait des camarades qui
ont décidé de soutenir ma ronde on leur
a dit de soin vos points des congés du
parti pour vous exprimer c'est une règle
qui n'existe pas mais c'est utiliser et
on a été obligé de dire attention et on
ne peut pas avoir deux bébés aiment
qu'ils expriment donc on a suspendu pour
qu'ils puissent faire leur campagne
tranquillement d'ailleurs il ya
troisième que vous citez jamais qui
daniel rubin qui a demandé une mise en
projet du parti
il est juste là présent en mise en congé
du parti il a souhaité faire campagne
pour macron il est plus libérale est que
ne peut être que nous aidons qui lit
comme paul avec lui donc décision qui a
été prise
ils ont décidé après de de démissionner
nous avons pris acte mais aussi selon
droit cesser leur lors de le dos leurs
devoirs aussi de dire on va créer
quelque chose on va faire quelque chose
de nouveau je respecte beaucoup
communiqué laconique on a pris acte
justement c'est parce que ce sont des
camarades izon en sélection quand même
que c'est un soulagement ou non ils sont
partis cela m'a du tout allait bien mais
honnêtement franchement ce serait
hypocrite de dire on n'a pas été
attristé de ça avec les deux indiqué
fred et chaumet nous avons passé le
single pop est complète à fréquenter
sporadiquement le bpm bon alors et fred
et chaumet ici il on a connu une dizaine
d'années incroyablement riche
ils ont fait un travail considérable
région or on ne peut pas éclater de rire
et de joie quand on perd deux camarades
d'une chose respecter le choix il faut
pas les critiquer
vous allez travailler avec le quand même
on verra ça bon nous verrons dans le
temps rapidement le cas de daniel robin
vous l'avez évoqué il est toujours
en congé du parti mais elle est aussi
représentant officiel d' emmanuel macron
ouais ça car comment c'est devenu
compliqué oui c'est vrai mais bon on
verra bon il devra choisir nous sommes
rencontrés naturellement ça me paraît
évident on peut pas être dans deux
mouvements
donc il fera son choix j'ai roubaix
toujours été clair il le sera encore
parlons des législatives vous êtes
confiant à fort de france on n'ait
jamais confiant quand on va aux
élections de défendre le sentiment
d'avoir très très très bien travaillé c
était le quart de bleeckere montra
décembre 2015 et puis on n'est pas
choisie soit parce que il y à une
alliance de dernière minute donc on est
extrêmement prudent c'est pour ça
d'ailleurs que nous faisons campagne
degré de nombre et pour mobiliser sous
le thé dans la population ça nous a
beaucoup manqué il faut avoir
l'honnêteté de dire on était un petit
peu absent du terrain absent de la
proximité donc on essaie de réparer ça
on a essayé pendant un an de le faire on
continue et on verra mais ce que je
souhaite c'est que et d'essayer de
passer au premier tour c'est pas une
manière prétend ce que je dis simplement
parce qu'il ya des risques de l'alliance
au deuxième poteau
donc je la cite auprès de la population
dit en disant clairement ce qui s'est
passé en 2015 peut se reproduire en 2010
est non il faut être très prudent et se
mobiliser la seule chaussée sera très
difficile il ya beaucoup de candidats et
deuxièmement il y a aussi les cinq à
poussan qu'il faut faire plus une voix
plus un quart des inscrits ça ramène à
16500 moi c'est pas facile j'ai déjà
fait fin au veto aux municipales voilà
mais c'est possible mais ce sera
difficile
honnêtement sera divisé mais on se bat
pour sa chute les observateurs disent
qu'à partir qu'en dessous de 13 mille
voix le second tour serait complètement
pour être chaotique on verra mon jeu
serré mais vous savez les reports de
voix au deuxième tour c'est toujours
très compliqué avec dix candidats
déclarés à fort de france la campagne
risque d'être mouvementée et tendu
d'autant plus que vous adversaires
disent déjà que vous n'êtes pas sur le
tiret et vous êtes devenu le poteau
mitan des pleureurs j'ai lu ça sedan le
matin dans le continent le quotidien as
je sais pas ce que ça veut dire parce
que j'ai le sentiment franchement d'une
très grande sérénité quand on analyse un
analyse la situation
faut pas mélanger des élections il ya
les i si ce qu'ils disent à veules
m'entraîner sur la partie régionale jeu
en une phrase je peux leur dire que la
martinique est planté en martinique et
deux bouts henri plus rien ne se passe
mais c'est pas moi moi c'est le cas dit
il suffit d'écouter de la population
vous dire ayem bakaba c'est donc de ce
point de vue là c'est peut-être le
peuple qu'ils traitent de pleureurs quoi
donc c'est très clairement non non nous
considérons que la martinique mérite
mieux que ça mais nous sommes lanciné
son initiative le travail qui a été fait
considérable mais vraiment un bilan que
je considère comme très bien avec une
dizaine de rapports ou deux lois qui
portent
kikititi ponctuée par moi même plus de
600 amendements dont un moment très
important que je que kiki très cher pour
moi c'est la reconnaissance des plantes
médicinales locale la pharmacopée locale
grâce à ces amendements gagner à une
voie vers 2 heures du matin on a pu
faire reconnaître que en martinique qui
a une chaise biologique et que ce qu'on
appelait avant nos vies mais brasiers
sont reconnues déjà une vingtaine de
plantes qui sont actuellement en cours
de transformation est ce qu'un fort de
france vous ne risquez pas d'être
confrontée au syndrome du parti unique
et de l'usure du pouvoir
que cela entraîne des générations en
générations n'ont connu qu'un fort de
faster ppm non parce que vous qu on fait
je pense que vous confondez la fidélité
avec la division non c'est pas une
question on n'a jamais eu une pensée
unique le ppm est présent c est resté
très longtemps
nous sommes très fiers d'être fidèle à
nos principes on a beaucoup critiqué
comme vous avez dit tout à l'heure
d'avoir soutenu les socialistes jusqu'au
bout on a fait parce qu'on est
respectueux et est fidèle aux valeurs
dernière qu'elle serait une dernière
question vous aller siéger ou si vous
êtes élu à la majorité présidentielle ou
pas mais nous verrons ça d'abord le
parti progressiste martiniquais n'a pas
n'a pas changé elle n'est pas allée à en
marche et nous verrons après les
élections nous irons d'abord au nom du
peuple martiniquais ono du ppm et ancien
salon serge et en fonction de
l'organisation du résultat nation merci
serge letchimy bonne journée aller coûte
de ne progresser
[Musique]